[Music]
Love Don't rescue
me I've got nowhere better I want to
be I want to be held but not be
Holden standing my ground with one eye
[Music]
open this
fight doesn't quite
[Music]
add
love I thought you were AF
freid but now I'm on the hook for all
you've given
me doesn't matter what I say or think or
do you see what you see with the lens
you're looking
through this
fight keeps me t
to the worst in
me and it's killing
me killing
[Music]
me
love I'm losing my
voice you leted me to
believe I had a
choice but let's
pause retract down
close you could take my side while I
take
[Music]
yours then
fight keeps me tied to the worst in
me and it's killing
[Music]
me killing
me
[Music]
love come rescue
me I've got
nowhere better I want to
be this
fight keeps me tied to the worst in
me and it's killing
[Music]
me killing
me
killing
[Music]
me killing
me uh well there's nowhere else I'd
rather be right
now
to thank you the for this thank you for
the private concert you're amazing you
really are amazing and it was a pleasure
to meet you and really a pleasure to
talk to you today do I get a private
concert now if you playing chess with
yourself
yeah we were out of time so we got to
go